I'm gonna talk to you about a
computational approach to game theory
this arose out of a class that I taught
at Milwaukee School of Engineering where
I'm an adjunct professor and I convinced
the the department that they should
learn they should have a course on
Wolfram that they should have a course
on game theory and they should have a
course on dynamic game theory and I was
a person to teach that course and they
said that would be great
and they gave me an elective course and
I had software engineering Electrical
Engineering and computer engineering
students so they were it was quite a mix
so that's what I'm going to talk about
I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
how I set the course up first of all
Milwaukee is on a quarter system and so
the course was a one quarter 10-week
course
so I'll these were the course goals
it's an accredited program at Milwaukee
School of Engineering so they're all
into saying what are the course outcomes
so you have to say say pretty clearly so
by the end of the course I wanted them
to be proficient in computer
computational engineering using
Mathematica I want them to be able to
understand dynamic thinking how to apply
systems thinking get the basic concepts
of the theory of games basic concepts of
how you go beyond systems thinking and
apply it to a dynamic theory of games
and then know at least how to build a
simple one person game two-person game
and we never got the three person but if
they got this far they should be in
pretty good shape so I would hope that
they would understand some advanced
concepts and at the end I hope that they
could actually apply this in the real
world the course was built around using
Mathematica notebooks and I gave labs
homeworks midterms and a final all using
a mathematical notebook so we went back
and forth between Mathematica and game
theory so I started him off with basic
hello world
problem and I'm gonna write up this this
disparate group of people so they have
different skills and things that they
know but basically a world arithmetic
lists and plots was was something they
could all understand and actually make
made sure that they understood how to
use a notebook then I gave them a simple
game theory example and we built us up
in pieces by the way this is the
notebook I have here is an example of
the end notebook it's not they didn't
get this whole thing all at once but it
was built incremental e so you're seeing
the final product then I went back to
lists and images and then lab 4 was kind
of was the key lab because solvers
helped me distinguish between different
disciplines that I had so for example
people that knew how to do solve were
primarily computer engineers because
they did a lot of circuit problems and
they were always faced with solving you
know five equations and 5 unknowns that
were basically linear in it so this was
a big help so they could identify with
that our saw was very useful for the
software engineers who in their
algorithms course always tried to figure
out how long that would take an
algorithm to compute a particular kind
of problem and so there's recurrence
solutions and D saw was very useful for
the electrical engineers because they
had some remnant of thinking about
differential equations then homework 5
and by the way these 5 1 2 3 4 5 go by
the week's so the fifth week we started
with game theory examples six week we
were sort of in the middle of doing like
midterms and in the seventh week we
moved into dynamic theory and then the
eighth week the lab was they had to come
up with their own project and it's a
little bit about that in a second
for the textbooks for the wolfram stuff
i
I picked this elementary book from
Wolfram which actually fits perfectly
for the engineering students I should
have said at the beginning these are
juniors and seniors and as engineering
students they've all had two years of
calculus they've had a variety of math
courses often they've had discrete math
improbability so that they know a fair
amount but this book taught him the
Mathematica at a level that that was was
like a common language and then they
could use their domain knowledge to go
much further which they did for the game
theory I published a book on the dynamic
theory last year so I used that as the
text and then the structure of the
notebook was we would have an in there
was an initialization part and they
would provide a game matrix and then it
would produce the harmonic flows and
they could go from there and what was
kind of interesting was doing the
midterm and final using the notebook I
basically had a contract I'd say here
here's the notebook when you're done
email it to me and then come up and tell
and when I get the email I'll write down
that you sent it so they were on their
own to create their notebook and they
were pretty good about that so there
were some challenges interestingly
enough one of the first challenges is
fear of calculus more generally fear of
mathematics I don't know if any of you
have had that experience but so I had to
overcome that the mixture of backgrounds
as I mentioned and the Mathematica
approach really helped deal with those
things so one of the first homework
exercises was for them to okay take a
game that's really trivial like
tic-tac-toe and I said okay how many of
you know what the solution is for what
how you should play the game so oh yeah
half the class know how to do that
so I said okay the way you play the game
is in an extensive form now I want you
to form the way that the way my Norman
and Morgenstern said you should do it as
an intensive game listing out all the
strategies of what I do what they do
what I do what they do until I get to
the end so they worked hard at it this
was a hard problem for them to do three
or four people in the class realized
however that if you went to Wolfram's
natural language and typed in
tic-tac-toe it had the answer to the
homework so there's this tic-tac-toe
game and here are all the strategies
that are nicely laid out from from the
Wolfram language so this I got some
converts by the way at this point they
said okay maybe this is not so crazy so
my goal was to bring students with all
their different backgrounds clearly by
halfway through the course some of the
students were able to go beyond the
simple game theory and by the way I had
to build up game theory from scratch
it's not like I it was a given so I had
to teach them all about game theory and
Nash equilibrium and I don't even the
guess that everybody here understands
all of that so what were the
deliverables I can say click this
they had to get in order to pass the
course they had to do the midterm and
final ahead deal with the labs and they
had to get a good grade on it
and I graded them by the way on their
style for their notebooks so they
actually had to do a reasonable job on
there so fast forward where did I get to
by the end okay these are a list of the
projects that they came up with a number
of them came up with variants of the
game of chicken you know the chicken two
cars come at each other and do you swear
you're not swerve tragedy in the Commons
Oh some variation of a model that it's
called work wealth of wisdom there were
people who were interested in baseball
strategies football strategies do you
PSTU not pass one of the most
interesting ones inventive ones was an
internet card trading game because the
game is interesting they're trading
cards but they were able to get the
trade out the payoff matrix using online
stuff these games are played massively
with lots and lots of people play it
over and over again so they did a very
good job of getting the raw data for
that so here's an example of the
notebook that they had they would have
some initializations by the way they
didn't have to go through and pull down
this stuff but it was there if they
wanted it and in the course of the
during the course of teaching them they
they learn a lot of useful methods which
then got incorporated into the useful
methods category but once it was there
they didn't have to go back to it I gave
them a whole host of games over the
duration of the course oops I don't want
to do that back
I took games from variety of sources
things that they gave me games from the
Cold War from the RAND Corporation there
are lots of books about game theory so I
summarized games two strategies ten
strategies 20 strategies they were all
quite different and go down if they
wanted there was some background
information that I was willing to give
them occasionally I would have to do a
little bit of math teaching so I'd have
to remind them what is the chain rule
because I was going to use it but I had
that in the wings but it was also part
of their notebook told them what is the
essential point of the dynamic theory I
said it's not Bayesian it's looking for
this shortest path that's very different
and it's built on geometry so every now
and then I would have to say oh by the
way here's a whole bunch of stuff you
need to know about geometry if you care
and if you don't care well you put this
back up again so what did they have to
do first their introduction to get to a
game was to describe it they had to say
what's the game I'm gonna do so here was
an example of the chicken game it was
the student called it econo chicken and
so they said okay one aims to crash one
swerves to person two aims to crash two
swerves come up with a simple game
matrix if you want to personalize some
of the strings you can do that then you
had to specify a couple of things to get
going and then you could play with the
couple of things and so there was a some
pieces that you would have to play with
the basically the first couple of lines
here saying what kind of game it was and
then
the next set of things were things that
they had learned and earlier about game
theory so they could go back and
replicate it what they had learned then
they would come down and say the key
issue here for the kind of dynamic game
we're gonna talk about is how you
disrupt an equilibrium so this part they
would have to set out and they would say
okay we're going to disrupt it such in
such a way and then run the notebook
they might run the notebook multiple
times and the result usually was enough
to get to this point what would be the
basic change in time for the different
strategies that you might play so they
would get to this part and they'd say ok
blue is 1 aims to crash Green is 1
swerves and you can see blue and greens
oscillate back and forth so they have to
sort of think through what does that all
mean and then write a little paragraph
at the end then there were a number of
other sections that they could go on and
and think about they were kind of hints
of other ways of thinking about the
problem but in the end their piece was
this thing at the bottom they would have
to write the paragraph about what does
it all mean in a 10-week course there
was a lot of stuff that I couldn't cover
but I did you know like little culture
lectures this part of game theory had
essentially two different physical
mechanisms that once you got rid of the
equilibrium what was underneath it
whatever the processes that determined
it one is essentially the payoff payoff
is kind of like a magnetic field
particles and magnetic fields can go
straight and you don't see anything
interesting but if you push a particle
off and make it rotate it will rotate
based upon the strength of the magnetic
field see all of a sudden you learn that
the magnetic field wasn't just a
direction but it also had a strength the
other thing is player valuations which
is a sort of analogy to an electric
field that things can
bias somebody can buy us you towards
this direction or biases towards that
there are in fact a number of other
physical processes that might affect
games some of them sort of rational
thinking other things that are probably
related to irrational thinking just how
people can collaborate with each other
so I gave them some of that
unfortunately the the mathematics got
harder which was okay because I have a
notebook the first part of the
mathematics well essentially you had to
solve ordinary differential equation for
the the more advanced stuff he had to
solve partial differential equations
that are nonlinear so this section would
set up how you do the we just set up
four of them without going into what
they were doing and then you could
iterate your nonlinear differential
equation multiple times and it would
nicely converge to an answer so if they
did that they would get an answer or I
would do it for him as part of the
culture and there are in fact other
things that you can also do which is we
just talked about disruptions which are
essentially in space but you could have
disruptions in time like in the
electrical engineering where you have a
impulse right and then things oscillate
as a function of that impulse in time so
you can do exactly the same thing here
so there was a whole section on that so
what did I learn from all this I started
off with a computational approaches to
game theory so one of my conclusions was
I should probably not be shy but it was
a computational approach to how you make
decisions it was more general than game
theory that's the part that was new
focusing on games in their harmonic
behavior was in fact the right thing to
do it really quote resonated with the
students and I had a list of things
which I I learned if I taught the course
again I would probably change okay some
technical things about how they approach
game theory I would probably change I
was not even some of my thinking of
what sorts of behavior is harmonic
because the theory has more kinds of
harmonic behavior in it then I had first
thought about but they kept coming with
solutions that behaved in a way that I
didn't expect any when all but actually
that's quite correct this is actually
how it should go so I would put build
that into this start the chicken game
was very interesting and I learned from
that this is a really profound issue in
game theory when you have two different
Nash equilibria there's not a nice way
in game theory to combine them and the
dynamic theory has a rather nice way and
shows you can combine them all kinds of
different ways and I would probably
emphasize that a lot more about how in
like in a game of chicken these two
distinct Nash equilibria end up
combining and how you can go from even
though I think I'm gonna go straight and
he swerves what I ended up doing in some
solutions is I always swerve
nevertheless in other words I it's
counterintuitive so I do a better job
mine at the exercises I gave both the
mathematical exercises in the game
theory exercises keeping it at a low
level was really useful because that
allowed everybody to keep up and nobody
really got behind in this course believe
it or not even though if you think about
it the math was way beyond what they
remembered they'd all had been exposed
to some of this stuff but if I asked
them you know what is dy/dx equals zero
what's the solution to that I might not
get an answer so but Mathematica gave
them an answer and then with all yeah
yeah right I get it
the quarter system is good and bad that
was another issue I would love to teach
maybe a two quarter system on this
although the quarter system is good in
the sense that it keeps you moving so we
got to the end of the course and they
learn awful lot before
they realized they had learned an awful
lot and then if I thought a second
course I would probably then be work
more on projects that they could come up
with and and then dive a little bit
deeper into some of the mechanisms that
might occur to them that might be
applicable to these heart more
complicated things so I think in strict
time I usually try to keep my time
pretty accurate I think I'm exactly a
twenty right teaching yet so I'd be
really happy to take questions if
anybody has and I apologize they didn't
you know show you an awful lot of the
stuff in the notebook but you can
download it there's I did a lot of
calculations in the notebook for them
and so there's a lot of stuff and some
of the calculations use simple Wolfram
languages some of those sort of arcane
kinds of constructions with at at and
all that kind of stuff so be happy to
introduce questions
I I thought about how to take this to
the next step and I'm talking to people
at Wolfram about how maybe to make this
no but you know like a book oh and if
not and I would really you know it would
be fun to make the course available but
yeah but I don't we talk afterwards I go
follow up with that yeah
well I gave the course in the spring so
you might think I don't have an awful
lot of time but I right after the course
I got a request from one of my students
from that course to write a letter of
recommendation to various graduate
schools because he now wants to go into
robotics and use decision theory as part
of his interest in robotics so he
connected the dots yeah
yes
no first let me see if I can back up and
find it quickly
that's initializations
so this matrix at the bottom was called
modern meta that was the input for the
utility for playing these different
strategies these numbers point oh five
point oh seven these are the numbers the
utility numbers that he got by looking
at massive numbers of games being played
on the Internet and it was available to
him so this is where the input numbers
came in and then based upon this he was
then he then created the the game matrix
he created the other pieces of the model
then he created a okay let's try a
disruption where people take a strategy
that everybody who plays training games
knows is not really the optimal strategy
to your to strategy and then you would
say well - the tier chess strategy goes
up but as it goes up the the Tier one
strategy starts coming back and they
start trading places and so he was able
to make some conclusions he had a little
bit of difficulty about getting the
actual numbers because it someone that
was proprietary and the owners of the
game kind of made it difficult to find
but he was still able to pull out some
of the most interesting numbers I hope
that answers your question
oh right yes correct
because there are more mechanisms of
decision theory but as any let me give
it a physics example because it's easy
because the game theory gets rid okay I
can't have a car on a road right and and
I simply pay attention to the fact that
it moves at a certain speed in a certain
direction I don't necessarily have to
take into account the fact that it's on
the road and it's not falling through
the road all right so there's a big
thing in physics where you identify what
are the active things that you want to
talk about what are the inactive things
that you don't necessarily want to talk
about but you need to know how much
energy they take away from you right so
a couple of the areas that I talked
about like the idea of ownership
introduces something like a force or a
pressure these don't have to do with the
people playing the game as much as all
the people that you're ignoring so you
have to take into account those external
forces you have to take into account the
fact that people can collaborate okay
and these forces are not harmonic payoff
forces there are sort of gradient forces
where they just glom together and they
can form collaborations or they cannot
so I'd like to explore how those things
work in a theoretical model where you're
just taking the shortest path but
allowing all the forces to operate in a
controlled way where you say let's add
this force let's see what happens let's
add that force let's see what happens
okay well thank you very much
[Applause]